think what do you think men want no one  at a time sorry I I couldn't tell you  because  I feel like  again I've never been in a relationship  but I've chatted to quite a few guys and  it seems like it's not even that I don't  live up to their standards I feel like  I'm never what they want and I'm like is  it looks okay apparently I checked that  box but they still don't want me it's a  personality yeah you're cool your Vibes  but I don't want a wife you like I don't  I don't get it you say you want  personality but you still go and try and  treat a girl like a hoe and I know this  is not all guys I understand that and  maybe this is just the guys I attract I  don't know what I'm doing but okay cool  but I just feel like  maybe society as a whole not everyone  we do care a lot about looks and I think  that is a lot about like the first it's  just it's very superficial I think